in the 20 years since 9 11 the u.s has
spent over 2 trillion on the war in
afghanistan that's 300 million dollars
per day every day for two decades
or 50 000 for every person in
afghanistan's population of 40 million
you could also look at it this way
america has spent more trying to keep
the taliban at bay than the net worths
of jeff bezos elon musk bill gates and
the 30 richest billionaires in america
all put together 800 billion dollars was
allocated to direct war fighting costs
85 billion dollars was spent to train
the afghan military which ended up
folding and surrendering in the weeks
since the pentagon closed bagram air
force base in july this effectively
removed american air support against the
taliban
750 million dollars a year was allocated
to salaries for afghan soldiers and then
there's the human cost
47 000 afghan civilians dead
69 000 afghan security forces over 3 500
coalition troops 2 500 of them u.s
military personnel 4 000 u.s contractors
figures for dead opposition fighters are
estimated at around 51 000
the cost so far to care for the 20 000
americans wounded in the conflict has
been about 300 billion dollars with
another half trillion or so expected to
come
the united states financed the war with
borrowed money researchers at brown
university estimate more than 500
billion dollars in interest has already
been paid
they think that by 2050 the cost of
interest alone on our afghan war debt
could reach 6.5 trillion dollars that
equals about 20 thousand dollars for
every u.s citizen